Der Schweizer Urlaubsort Laax in einem
der größten Skigebiete Europas
will der erste CO2-neutrale
Wintersportort in den Alpen werden.
Zum Beispiel mit Strom aus
Wind-, Wasser- und Sonnenkraft.
Durch GPS-Steuerung verbrauchen
Schneekanonen weniger Wasser und
Energie, Pistenraupen mit Hybridmotoren
schonen die Ressourcen.
Wir finden es sehr wichtig, uns
um die Umwelt zu kümmern.
Denn wir möchten, dass unsere Enkel
hier auch Ski fahren können.
Wir müssen alles daran setzen,
dass der Planet und ein Paradies
wie dieses nicht zerstört werden.
Wir müssen versuchen, unser Leben
zu ändern und das, was wir tun.
Und wenn Laax Schritte unternimmt
- das ist großartig.
Doch nicht alle sehen das so rosig.
Barbara Wülser von der internationalen
Alpenschutzkommission (CIPRA) steht auch
dem Wintersport in Laax kritisch gegenüber.
Verregneter Kunstschnee - ist es das,
was die Leute suchen hier,
auf über 1.100 Metern?
Der Wintersport hat vor allem
Auswirkungen auf die Landschaft
mit ihrer ganzen Infrastruktur,
vom Lärm, von den Emissionen.
Und mit dem enormen Strom und
Energieverbrauch des Kunstschnees
kommen da noch weitere Faktoren hinzu,
die der Natur schaden,
die der Biodiversität schaden und eigentlich
das zerstören, was die Leute
hier in den Alpen suchen:
nämlich Natur, Landschaft, Erholung.
Für nachhaltige Erholung sollen
in Laax Hotelgebäude sorgen,
die mit Werkstoffen aus der Region
energieeffizient gebaut worden sind.
Eine Skistadt, in der man essen,
feiern und schlafen kann.
Wie auch im "Riders Hotel",
das seinen Gästen ein ganzheitliches
Bewusstsein vermitteln will.
Die reduzierte Einrichtung soll ein Symbol
gegen die Wegwerfgesellschaft sein.
Wir haben zum Beispiel hier die Stühle,
die „Horgenglarus“-Stühle aus Glarus.
Ein sehr nachhaltiges Produkt,
auch die verlieren den Wert nie,
weil die gehen nie kaputt.
Oder die kann man reparieren,
da bekommen wir Teile.
Das Foyer wird von
Vintage-Möbeln dominiert.
Und im Restaurant kommen ausschließlich
vegetarische Gerichte auf den Tisch.
Küchenchef Pascal Bertschinger
reduziert auch beim Kochen CO2,
denn der Strom des Hotels wird aus
Wasserkraft und Sonnenenergie erzeugt.
Dennoch: Barbara Wülser
sind diese Neubauten
inmitten der Alpen ein Dorn im Auge.
Für das geben die Leute
Tausende von Franken aus…?
Ich denke, das Wichtigste ist, dass man die
natürlichen Gegebenheiten respektiert.
Dass man die Identifikation
behält zu dem Lebensraum,
den wir hier haben, dass man das sieht, was
wir hier haben, und das auch erfahren kann.
So wie in Tenna im Safiental,
etwa 30 Kilometer von Laax entfernt.
In dem kleinen Dorf mit rund 100 Einwohnern
werden schlichte Fremdenzimmer
für Touristen vermietet.
Es gibt einen Schlepplift im Ort,
und der wird mit Solarstrom betrieben.
Edi Schaufelberger ist einer
der Bewohner von Tenna,
die sich hier für einen
sanften Tourismus engagieren.
Wir fahren jetzt am Solarskilift Tenna,
weltweit dem ersten, und lassen uns mit
Solarenergie den Berg hochziehen.
Wir sind, so gut es uns gelingt, authentisch.
Wir geben das, was wir hier haben und wie
wir das ganze Jahr eigentlich hier leben.
In den kleinen Ort Tenna kommen
die Touristen meist mit dem Bus
anstatt mit dem eigenen Auto
- entscheidend für den CO2-Abdruck.
Doch die große Masse der Skifahrer kann
natürlich nicht in Orte wie Tenna ausweichen.
Auch die großen Wintersportzentren
müssen handeln.
Dass man versucht, eben mit kleinen
Initiativen, das zu verbessern, was da ist.
Laax kann vielleicht ein Vorbild sein,
und es ist auch ein Beitrag,
vielleicht ein kleiner, einer
nachhaltigen Entwicklung.
Letztlich ist es
natürlich auch eine Inszenierung,
weil heute ist Nachhaltigkeit
auch ein Lifestyle,
und den will man bedienen
- dieses Bedürfnis der Gäste.
Wir denken an
die ganz junge Generation schon,
die jetzt demonstrieren usw.,
die irgendwann dann hier
auch in die Ferien kommen.
Skifahren mit gutem Gewissen?
Laax tut zumindest einiges,
damit umweltbewusste Skifahrer
den Wintersport nicht
komplett aufgeben müssen.